ok let's get into audience questions for
the week and some really good ones first
one is about these two special elections
in California and Wisconsin the question
is hey David do California and Wisconsin
special elections going to Republicans
mean an inevitable disaster for
Democrats in November of 2020 the answer
is no the answer is no so if you've not
been following these two races you had
the 7th congressional district in
Wisconsin and the twenty fifth
Congressional District in California two
special elections both went to the
Republican candidates Mike Garcia
defeating Christie Smith in California's
25th Wisconsin's seventh went to the
Republican candidate Tom Tiffany so
let's talk first about California and
then about Wisconsin but before we even
do that special elections tend to have
low turnout and in particular we know
that one party benefits from lower
turnout Republicans benefit from lower
turnout so you have to be very careful
about taking especially not just any
special election but in the case of
California's 25th a special election in
a historically red district at least
when it comes to members of Congress and
saying hey alert low turnout special
election went to the Republican this
spells trouble in the fall it could
there could be trouble in the fall for
Democrats and for Joe Biden in the 25th
but this is not evidence of it so let's
start with California 25th California
25th is this district that was held by
Democratic congresswoman Katie Hill
Katie hill ended up resigning she
resigned because she was involved in a
relationship with a staffer the nothing
illegal took place but it does violate
House Ethics guidelines and so she
resigned so a couple of things then went
on you had this jungle primary for the
November race simultaneously with the
special election primary you with the
special election you had a blowback
effect where this is you know they call
it a purple district but this was a seat
that was held for 25 years by Republican
buck McKeon and then for four years by
Republican Steve Knight they call it a
pur purple district but it's
a Republican held district at the
Congressional level for a really really
long time and then it went to Katie Hill
and Katie Hill had to resign and there
was a blowback effect to some degree
that has nothing to do with what we
would expect to see in the fall so
that's number one
Republicans are seeing the headline as
hey a Republican won a seat that was
just held by a Democrat this is great
for Republicans the real story is that
Katie Hill had taken the seat that had
been held by Republicans for a really
long time and it doesn't tell us that
Trump is going to start winning blue
states in 2020 then you get to
Wisconsin's seventh I actually think
that Wisconsin's seventh although it got
less attention than could the California
25th is more relevant for thinking about
2020 if you look at the results of the
Wisconsin's seventh special election
just recently and compare it to how
those areas voted in 2016 there was
really no major shift if you look at the
elements that make up the Wisconsin
seventh and you look at how did they
vote on Trump versus Hillary in 2016 and
how did they vote for Tiffany versus the
Democratic challenger in that recent
special election you could say well
maybe I believe it's pronounced an Ida
or an ADA in Ada County that might be a
flip that came within twenty votes in
the judicial election that just took
place it's gonna be pretty similar to
2016 so Wisconsin's 7th is potentially
more consequential when thinking about
2020 because any small change in
Wisconsin could flip the state when you
look at California you can argue about
California's 25th as a sort of
guideposts for what might happen bigger
picture in California but Trump's not
gonna win California no matter what
right Katie Hill resigned she was a
Democrat now a Republican won been a
Republican state for decades before it
was Katie it doesn't matter because
Biden's going to win California in
Wisconsin even these small shifts the
margin was small enough in Wisconsin I
don't remember exactly what I think was
about 20,000 votes
that is a state that if the wind blows
one way versus the other if older voters
abandoned Trump and go to Biden the way
we've been seeing you could actually get
a different result where Donald Trump
doesn't win Wisconsin so I don't think
either tells us what is in store for
November but if I were to look at one of
them as maybe being a more impactful
signal it would be looking at
Wisconsin's seventh not California's
25th